[Music]
all right the u.s department of
education is opening civil rights
investigations into those five
republican-led states that have banned
or limited mass requirements in schools
including utah oklahoma iowa tennessee
and south carolina the education
secretary miguel cardona saying quote
state bans on universal indoor masking
are putting their children at risk and
preventing them from accessing in-person
learning equally it's simply
unacceptable that state leaders are
putting politics over the health and
education of the students
all right for a conversation about this
let's bring in fox news contributors
civil rights attorney and former history
teacher and he never lets us forget that
leo terrell leo
steve thanks for having me i couldn't
sleep last night i wanted to talk about
this because of the just outrageous
accusation that the secretary of
education is making i want to be very
clear steve there is no civil rights
violation there is no violation of the
rehabilitation act or the american
disability act this is a political witch
hunt on the federal government to try to
impose federal mandates on states
regarding masking kids steve where's the
medical evidence that any kid who has a
disability is being denied a quality
education it's strictly political it's a
backdoor way to impose mass mandate by
joe biden administration
well the department of office of civil
rights announced the investigations and
they say those states have issued
varying prohibitions on mass
requirements which the office says could
prevent some students from safely
attending school
and also is concerned about their health
and things like that you know leo i was
talking to somebody
who lives across the street from me uh
yesterday she's been going to the town
meetings regarding getting kids back to
school in about a week
and our town is split right down the
middle half the parents want the kids in
mass half the parents don't want the
kids in mass and so they're figuring it
out out on the local level
isn't that the way it's supposed to work
yes steve and here's the thing about it
you have to understand that the byte
administration wants the pandemic to
continue they want federal control it's
a dependency and a power argument this
should be handled on the school level on
the district level and steve here's the
part that is so obvious if there was a
disability violation do you see any of
these families in these local districts
in these in these republican states
making this allegation this is a game
this is they're using the the pandemic
as an excuse to impose power there is no
there i want to be clear
this is in my wheelhouse miguel
cardona's accusation or investigation is
a fraud because there is no ada
violation one last point it makes the
assumption that the kids the ones who
are disabled must wear a mask or
alternatively everyone else has to wear
a mask where's the medical evidence i
submit to you there isn't any
well and and the cdc hasn't looked at
kids in mass because maybe they don't
want to know exactly how effective they
are for whatever reason
exactly steve i'm telling you i want to
be clear about this because this is what
fox
hired me for i'm a civil rights servant
there is no ada violation there's none
this is a political stunt by the bible
administration to try to go back door to
impose federal mandate of masking bring
on dr nicole and the other doctors you
have here there's none there is no
justification ada is not in play all
right leo that's why we woke you up
early out there where it's coming up on
five o'clock in the morning leo terrell
folks thank you very much glad to be
here